hello everyone
my name is orit yes
and
i study insurance
telling people that you study insurance
is not a good way to start a
conversation
in fact if ever you need to end the
conversation
try it tell people you study insurance
people don't want to talk about
insurance they don't think it's all that
exciting
but i disagree
i find insurance fascinating in fact i
find it magical
and today i'd like to show you why
now the famous author franz kafka
used to work for an insurance company in
prague and this is what kafka had to say
about insurance he said
insurance is like a religion
insurance is like a primitive religion
it's the religion of people who believe
that by having insurance
they can ward off evil
so according to kafka what leads us to
buy insurance is not rational thinking
but magical thinking
it's the belief that if i have insurance
somehow
magically
those negative events that i fear in the
future they are not going to happen
of course this is totally irrational
it's like believing that if you have an
umbrella it's not going to rain
if your car gets stolen yes the
insurance company will cushion the blow
with the compensation money you could
probably afford a new car
but the fact that you have insurance
does not make your car less likely to be
stolen the risk is the same whether you
are insured or not
so are people this naive do they really
believe that if they have insurance they
are less at risk
yes
perhaps not consciously but they do let
me show you
in one of my studies i asked people to
predict what is the likelihood that in
the future they will suffer all kinds of
medical misfortune
that they will need an operation
physiotherapy or nursing care
another group was asked to make the same
predictions but we first asked them
do you have health insurance
and of course they do israel has
universal coverage
reminding people that they have health
insurance had a fascinating effect it
made them feel less at risk
surprisingly the effect was not limited
to medical problems
it also made them believe that they are
less likely to lose money
and my personal favorite
asking people in tel aviv if they have
health insurance
made the prospect of a war in europe
seem less likely
and that's magic kafka was
right
there is an interesting paradox here
we buy insurance against those events
that we fear the most
but once we are armed with this
protection measure
we feel that we are no longer at risk
somehow
magically
and this protection effect is not unique
to insurance policies we see it with
other protection measures as well let me
show you
in 2012
the citizens of israel were very worried
about a possible military attack by iran
and the government was distributing gas
masks to all the citizens
at the time we called people and asked
them to predict what are the chances
that iran would attack israel with
weapons of mass destruction
the ratings were quite high people were
worried
but if we first asked them do you have a
gas mask
then the ratings dropped dramatically
and that's magic apart from the fact
that gas masks are
largely useless against weapons of mass
destruction
the fact that you have a gas mask
is unlikely to affect the strategic or
the
tactical decision of a foreign power
we have to remember
insurance is an antidote it's not a
vaccine it doesn't ward off evil it
doesn't eliminate the risks that we face
however when it comes to insurance the
distinction between an antidote and a
vaccine
somehow gets blurred in our minds
why does it happen
it happens because people are not that
good
at assessing risks rationally
let me give you an example
when i arranged my flight to come here i
had to decide if i wanted to buy travel
insurance
rationally i should have based this
decision on several considerations
the price of the policy of course
the value of my luggage
the aggravation that i'm likely to
experience if my luggage gets lost and
of course the likelihood of such an
event right
but most of the time we're just too busy
to make such rational calculations and
anyway i doubt that lufthansa
are very keen to share the damage
statistics with me
so what do we do instead we rely on our
intuition
so how do we evaluate risks intuitively
we start by imagining the outcomes that
we fear
so here i am it's late at night i'm
sitting at this airport
all the other passengers already
collected their luggage and left
i realized that my own suitcase is now
probably heading to the north pole
thinking about this scenario creates
anxiety
and then we use the level of anxiety
that we feel in order to assess the
probability
so if i'm feeling terrified
i will infer that the risk of such an
event is quite
high but you see this is an intuitive
risk estimate it is entirely
psychological and emotion based which is
why it is also highly susceptible to the
magic of insurance
insurance reduces our anxiety
first because the outcomes that we
imagine are suddenly less scream
yes i'm sitting at the airport yes it's
late at night all the other passengers
had left but
there will be this guy there they would
give me a voucher eventually i will get
compensated it's okay
also
because
we are conditioned to associate
insurance with safety security
tranquility and peace of mind
and if i'm feeling less anxious
i would infer that the risk is not that
high so there you have it i have
insurance and the risk is gone
but why do we associate insurance with
peace of mind
well
first in many languages this is exactly
what the word insurance means it comes
from the word sure
which means lack of doubts
no unknowns that would
sneak up and bite you in the future
right
but also because traditionally this is
how
insurance was promoted
let me show you an example
this is a lovely advertising toy that
was distributed to
visitors at the british exhibition in
1924
so you see this guy and he looks
terrified he is barraged by the bricks
of doom
fire accident
falling on his head
and the tag of the bottom it reads
anxiety which perfectly describes the
guy's expression but if you pull on that
tag
something slides inside
and the guy transforms
first he now has the protection of the
potential insurance helmet
and his expression is changed into a
smile you know why because
prudential insurance dispel anxiety
modern images of insurance convey the
same message
insurance logos often incorporate
supporting hand belows and umbrellas
above ultimate protection
and then
travel insurance ads
they could easily be mistaken for
vacation brochures right romantic
couples exotic islands palm trees
and if for some reason you need
images of smiling happy people wearing
white
do an image google search with the words
pension plans or health insurance
insurance ads rarely show you sick
people smashed cars torn suitcase the
message is loud and clear you have
insurance
all is well in the world
however to get us to buy insurance
the promoters must also work our fears
which is why right after you paid a lot
of money for a top of the line
refrigerator the same seller who just
moments ago were explaining how reliable
this product is
is now telling you that it may break
down at any moment which is why you
should buy the extended warranty
and with some credit cards you could get
free travel insurance all you need to do
is to call the agent
but when you make this call you are told
yeah but the free deal is only for the
basic
plan basic plan doesn't sound good
already right
and then you get to hear a list of
things that you are not covered against
like fires and heart lung transplant and
floods etc
but if you pay one more dollar a day
right
and your active imagination does the
rest with each item on the list your
anxiety is mounting
and you don't ask yourself hey i'm going
to paris why would i care about that
tsunami
you pay the dollar and all is well in
the world again
in fact
just realizing that we are not covered
against something
is enough to distort our perception of
risk
i once asked people to imagine in one of
my studies that they are going to go on
a trip and they plan to buy travel
insurance at the airport
but by the time they reached the counter
boarding had already started and they
have to board that airplane painfully
aware that they are not covered
and then i asked them to assess all kind
of travel related risks
and these were dramatically inflated
compared to the ratings of people who
did have insurance
for example lost luggage the risk of
lost luggage almost 50 percent
what are the chances that you will need
hospitalization almost 45 percent where
45
and how about you will need to be
rescued 31 percent i remember the first
time i saw this data i was speechless i
was thinking
guys
if this is what you believe why would
you ever leave home you know
yeah
boarding an airplane with no insurance
is tempting fate
it's like realizing that your insurance
policy had just expired and not renewing
it grave danger indeed
your appliances they know
you know
so
we buy insurance and restore our peace
of mind and now you are probably asking
yourself but peace of mind is good
what's wrong with peace of mind right
what's the problem
the problem is that we are highly likely
to be overinsured
what does it
mean well first we may be protecting
ourselves against really unlikely events
like a tsunami in paris
or we may be paying a lot to prevent a
trivial
loss
does it really make sense to extend the
warranty on an old washing machine
and if you will
examine your own policies back at home
many of you will find
that you have redundant coverage you are
paying
several policies on the same event
many of you
do that me included and i should know
better
so
this kind of behavior
can get people in debt and even if they
don't this is money that we could spend
in far more pleasurable ways
right at least i can
but selling peace of mind is a problem
for the insurance companies as well
why
the insurance companies are well aware
of the problem called moral hazard you
see when people are insured
they become negligent
they start living their valuables out in
the open they don't check their fire
alarms they drive faster
in short they act in ways which put them
at greater risk
now
the insurance companies they believe
that we behave like that because we know
that if something happened someone else
will pay
which is why many policies include
deductibles that's the money that come
out of your pocket right
so the deductibles
are there to make sure that some of the
risk will stay with the client
but based on the research that i just
shared with you it is entirely possible
that the reason that we are careless is
not just that we think that someone else
will pay
but it's also the magical belief that if
i have insurance it's not going to rain
the damage is not going to happen
and magical thinking is not susceptible
to deductibles
what are the lessons to be learned
for us
for you
next time you consider buying insurance
remember kafka
ask yourself
am i buying insurance for the right
reasons am i making sound economic
decisions or merely trying to please my
psyche
as for the insurance companies
i hope they will consider changing their
message
don't sell magical happiness encourage
us to buy insurance when it is
economically rational
and the responsible thing to do
and finally
guys i hope that next time someone say
i study insurance you would say
wonderful
please tell me more
thank you